chadwick boseman was a king both off
and on screen and he was royalty here at
the dolby theater in hollywood
home of the oscars black panther is the
only superhero movie ever to be
nominated for best picture
chadwick elevated every single project
he was involved with
and he touched so many lives around the
world
[Music]
this whole marvel thing is just like it
doesn't make any sense like you feel
like you're walking around in a dream
what is it in your decision-making
process for the characters you choose
i'm just praying it's not me
at the end of the day like acting is
acting you can look at it with the glass
half full or glass a glass half empty
and so i just choose to look at it with
the glass
full that outlook is no doubt what
helped chadwick persevere through his
four-year-long secret battle with colon
cancer
during which he became king t'challa
in what is now the most liked tweet in
history chadwick's team released the
news of his death friday
the 43 year old was first diagnosed with
stage three colon cancer
in 2016. it eventually developed into
stage four
his team also revealed the unimaginable
black panther avengers
marshall 21 bridges and most recently
the five bloods
were all quote filmed during and between
countless surgeries and chemotherapy
thurgood marshall the black panther
that's a lot
and you've morphed into these people to
be honest with you i'm just
just trying to take care of myself in
between that's the main thing
it is difficult but you know what would
i
would i rather be doing anything else
now today netflix was scheduled to
preview what may be chadwick's final
film
ma rainey's black bottom with viola
davis that has been delayed
chadwick knew being black panther was
bigger than him
to be young gifted and black we all know
what it's like
to be told that there is not a
place for you to be featured and that is
what
we went to work with every day during
production while his cancer diagnosis
was hidden
chadwick became a real-life hero for two
young children
also battling cancer throughout our
filming
i was communicating with them um
knowing that they were both terminal
thank you aka black panther
well i'm so excited thank you so
much and when i found out that they
yeah it's it's it means a lot et's last
interview was november 2019
where he talked about the future of the
black panther franchise
have you seen a script yet can i do you
give us a little money
[Laughter]
you know you talking about marvel like
some actors don't see the script the
whole time
so i can't tell you that on that day
hip hollywood asked about his noticeably
thinner physique
i noticed that you were slimmer though
did you drop some weight
from you know all of your like panthers
yeah i didn't want to be black what did
you do to lose the weight
right
in april when chadwick posted a video
commemorating what is typically jackie
robinson day
fans were alarmed by his dramatic weight
loss i can't think of a better time
to remember my hero two months later in
june
chadwick was noticeably absent from
press day for his netflix film
the five bloods i died for you bud
writer director spike lee says he had no
idea chadwick was ill when they shot the
film in the spring of 2019.
never complained he was there
every single minute chadwick's breakout
role was playing jackie robinson in the
2013 film 42
[Music]
this year due to covid jackie robinson
day was celebrated this past friday
the same day bozeman passed away he was
surrounded by his family including wife
taylor simone
whom he secretly married in the months
before his death
chadwick was notoriously private about
his personal life
he was first linked with taylor a
trained singer in 2015.
during the 2019 naacp image awards
they shared a rare moment of public
affection simone
with me every day i have to acknowledge
you right now love you
taylor was by chadwick's side during his
last public appearance
february 16th at the nba all-star game
e.t first met the then 36 year old
rising star in 2013
as he was promoting 42. i can't wait for
my mom and dad to see
i want them to see it at the premiere
and my dad you know
who is a baseball fan watching me play
baseball
at the premiere he told us his first big
red carpet
was a little overwhelming it's a lie i'm
not nervous
it's just exciting it's over stimulation
in a way but i'm taking it one thing at
a time
his career completely catapulted into
icon status
when the black panther first made his
way on screen in 2016's captain america
civil war did you expect that black
panther was going to be such the
breakout hit from civil war
i don't know if you could expect
something like that i'm happy that it
[Music]
happened